[Applause]
okay here's the thing all actors know
this
you can be primed to give the
performance of your life but if you show
up and your hair looks wrong
all anybody will be looking at is your
hair and if you show up and your costume
is wrong all anybody would be looking at
is your costume before you've even
spoken a line you're done
for best makeup and hairstyling five
different teams of three
are nominated these artists shared their
various paths to tonight
one began by doing makeup on himself
another got started by showing up on a
set at 3am to hold hairpins
others by working for free on small
independent films
here are the nominees for makeup and
hairstyle
emma maurice langen laura allen
claudius dolce
hillbilly elegy aaron krueger matthew
mungle
and patricia haney
ma rainey's black bottom sergio lopez
rivera
mia neal and jamika wilson
mank gigi williams kimberly spateri
and colleen lebath
pinocchio mark coulier dalia cooley and
francesco pegarote
um pegoretti excuse me
and the oscar goes to maharani's black
[Applause]
voters
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
make up
i was raised by my grandfather james
holland
he was an original tuskegee airman he
represented the u.s
in the first pan am games he went to
argentina he met evita he graduated from
northwestern university at a time that
they not
they did not allow blacks to stay on
campus so he stayed at the ymca
and after all of his accomplishments he
went back to his hometown
in hopes of becoming a teacher but they
did not hire blacks in the school system
so i want to say thank you to our
ancestors who put the work in
were denied but never gave up
and i also stand here as jamika and i
break this glass ceiling with so much
excitement for the future
because i can picture black trans women
standing up here and
ages and sisters and not latina sisters
and indigenous women and i know that one
day it won't be unusual
or groundbreaking it would just be
normal
thank you to the academy to netflix
to denzel washington to george c wolfe
to ann
roth to miss biola davis
to mateki anna
to andrea resnick to the spirit of my
rainy
thank you
you